well Intel wants to bring technology to
everyone on the planet and you need to
do that in an affordable way in a secure
way and you need to be in the way that
enriches and improves their lives
otherwise they won't pay for technology
and do it in a way that can reach
lower-income people as well even if they
share technology in my specific area I
focus on digital divide lower income and
spend a lot of time in the education
world primarily through government
leaders ministers of telecom ministers
of Education this is a finance to help
them implement these programs in their
countries what we do is we work with the
telecoms we work with the regulator's
the regulatory authorities and we've
worked on business models there where
broadband has become more and more
wireless these days rather than why had
its 3G its 4G that's what reaches the
people and in that we've worked with the
telecoms on lower-cost computers tablets
so they'll take their business models
and adjust them so you can have lower
tiers of pricing in the prepaid model
just like as happened on the voice file
that way you reach far far more people
now if you're reaching far far more
people people who take their computers
on from schools they can use them in the
schools the university students can
afford laptops and capabilities in there
so it's really about affordability and
reach and then Intel we just build the
comms communications capabilities into
every platform
well obviously over time the price of
computers has been coming down you can
you can get a fantastic computer
capability today for maybe for a $400
you can get entry level computers for
maybe $200 but then his hundred-dollar
tablets around and there's lower cost
than that smartphones and there's a
spectrum of capabilities obviously the
higher price ones do a bit more but you
can do some great basic computing
capabilities or the entry level computer
a tablet and a low-cost smartphone now
with that we found over the years that
the cost of the broadband can actually
be much higher than the cost of the
device as we work with the telecom
people on that prepaid model to drive
that down for example in Africa three
years ago the average price of broadband
was $30 a month well maybe two percent
of Africans could afford down so there
you can buy in $1.00 increments when you
have money so if you're not banks or you
want fractions of a dollar increment and
you're a university student who uses the
land in the day and once they're free to
dongle just for a small amount of work
in the evening you can do that and pay
one or two dollars a month and get
everything you need there as that makes
it much much more affordable rather than
to a 3% forwarding it may be 30 or 40
percent can afford it and that brings
the technology to make us more people
we'll reach for Intel Intel is not in
every country in the world we have a
hundred thousand employees and some
large company but what we do is we work
with partners local partners to
integrate and implement around the world
we may have 200,000 or more channel
partners that exist in every country on
the planet and those are the people that
can take that technology so the end
customer so if you look in Nigeria
there'll be many small Nigerian
companies that will take the platforms
there you look in keene you you look in
the Middle East each of them will have
their own local companies that tend to
have grown into local solution providers
local channel local distribution along
with a local telecom and the reaches by
partnering with them because it's their
direct customers and it's our indirect
customers because we're the Intel Inside
ingredient
private-public partnership is absolutely
critical in this because if you look at
say trying to reach the schools every
t-shirt were very laptop to drive their
education programs or if you look to try
and reach businesses that may be you
know someone's home far or someone small
business and there's a few people in
this you've absolutely got to reach
those both with solutions on
affordability that makes sense to them
and gives them value for the smellier
because it can be a big piece of the
disposable income so it's critical that
we work on it now when the government
comes in is the gum of the look ok I
want to modernize education well they're
going to set policies on electronic
books they'll set policies I want I want
computers and scores but the prior
industry will do more the implementation
how do you make that work how do you
make a network how do you train the
teachers we've trained 12 million
teachers worldwide with Intel teach as
you work with a Content companies and so
the private industry is more the how to
and the government is more a here's the
goals I'm say and then what we're trying
to do for my people in my country